hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend and I do I do need a friend
sometimes I make a friend and then I
quickly lose them and that's on me
I'm told I'm alienating and clingy but
that's not the important thing
that's from my father
um I'm here as always with Matt Gourley
and Sonoma Obsession and guys I have
some exciting
news for you which is that recently
I was in New York City and
um I started to hear a lot of there was
talk of gerbils all the new call let me
just update anybody for a long time
um katakai
uh was the catchphrase and I would get
catechized wherever I went and that's
people's way of letting them letting me
know that they listened to the podcast
um which was kind of fun and then uh not
too long ago I was telling a story uh
about uh when Mickey Rooney was on the
show many many years ago and he was
trying to invoke come up with the name
Richard Gere but he couldn't think of
his name and he said who is he who is he
you know that guy that actor and Andy
and I are both trying to help him and he
who said well tell us something about
him and Mickey Rooney said there was
talk of gerbils and Andy and I both
explode laughing and laugh for solid 40
minutes uh it was one of the most absurd
moments of my life which is really
saying something there was talk of
gerbils anyway we were talking about
that and then that we decided that
should be the new category and I'm very
impressed because I'm getting a lot of
there was talk of gerbils and I even had
one person one walk up behind me in a
restaurant and practically whisper in my
ear there was talk of gerbils Oh I
thought you're gonna say something else
happened behind you with a gerbil oh no
no no okay
um no no no the there's it doesn't count
if someone else has to place the gerbil
um There are rules to these things for
Christ's sake but anyway uh been kind of
cool it's working it's working people
are listening to it you feel
um inflated when you hear that like
that's a good thing when someone shouts
across a crowded
rooms yeah I'm walking down walking up
Fifth Avenue very crowded Street and
someone shouts from like 200 yards away
there was talk of church
feel about resuscitating like a like a
30 year old rumor about a beloved actor
actually you know he's pretty beloved
yeah and he's never obviously never
terrible podcast oh mad yeah
charbels can't get enough I don't think
they love him they do
um he provides Sanctuary anyway does he
get consent
no listen it's an insane rumor of course
it's not true there's no way that ever
happened but the fact first of all I
didn't resuscitate it it was Mickey
Rooney God Rest his soul who did it back
in 1993 on my show and then I just
happened to recall it I don't think that
that is technically me resuscitating the
rumor so um I think I'm in the clear hey
Sona think of all the amazing things in
life that are expressions of just you
yeah I mean like the child chocolate
that you had on your face when you came
in because you just ate that what was it
you were eating I was eating a giant
cookie giant cookie yeah and that's so
Sona okay or that song
that saw stream over and over again it's
just so you what's that song For You
Twinkle Twinkle Little Star yeah but
it's for my boys I know still it's nice
okay or you know that podcast that
comedy podcast you just gotta listen to
yeah Conan O'Brien needs a friend
exactly is that what you listen to in
your spare time yeah I love it
everything that makes you you makes all
the difference State Farm believes
Insurance should work the same way your
plan your coverage selections could be
personalized by you and only you that's
cool I shouldn't shout but this is how
strong I feel about it you better choose
a plan you want by picking the options
that fit you like choosing to bundle
your home and auto policies is what the
State Farm personal price plan is all
about getting the coverage you want at
an affordable price just for you call or
go to statefarm.com today to create your
State Farm personal price plan prices
vary by state options selected by
customers availability and eligibility
may vary you are keeping it alive in a
way you are really yeah people Google
told that rumor after you after they
listened to that segment and they're
like what Richard Gere did what you
think people didn't know I think that
there is a contingent of people Eduardo
saying he didn't know yeah younger
people might know okay Eduardo didn't
know yeah okay so now just because I
repeated what Mickey Rooney said you now
are aware of this you believe it
well guess what we have the gerbil he's
here and he's going on the record wow
what a get yeah
do a little uh it is all untrue it is
this is the Chiron that will go
underneath the gerbil got a great
podcast voice yeah
okay the gerbil is now saying and then
we just put this on a Chiron uh the
rumors are untrue I never even met Mr
gear Mr gear is an outstanding actor
absurd absurd allegations and I deny
them
it's clearly not true it's clearly not
true and so clearly not true I think it
it could be no no what are you doing
Sona yeah first of all it's an who would
a lot of people would no they wouldn't
would not have a lot of people using
specifics for Christ's sake no one wants
a gerbil they have claws that's not
gonna be good not if you declaw them I
always thought they wore mittens did you
get little gerbil mittens little boxing
gloves little boxing gloves and um but
also do you do they enter through a
habit Trail I always heard it was
through a cardboard uh tube I had to say
paper towel I pictured one of those
giant habit Trails that's literally yeah
going it's massive the gerbil's been
journeying for days no they entered
through it like a Home Depot pneumatic
deliver message delivery system oh God
[Music]
how many are going in there anyway no
it's completely untrue and I am as
shocked as anybody
by the allegation that I have
resuscitated this rumor because I would
not do that no I think there's a whole
generation of people now who know that
rumor because of you specifically and
they're they're
what that durable things about so every
time they say it there they mean that
you're ruining Richard Keeper's career
in any way hurting his career or well
although Barbara Walters in an interview
did ask him about it did you know that
really there's a Barbara Walters
interview where she says you know that
rumor and he's like oh my God yes so
Barbara Walters in her own way I think
Mickey Rooney and Barbara Walters were
the true criminals here and God Rest
both of their souls but they're the ones
that
the true criminals I'm just repeating
something I heard during one of my idol
chats what are we gonna do if we ever
have Richard Gere as a guest on this
show oh please that's what I'm saying I
think come on that ship sailed
[Laughter]
I love Richard Gere he's and I've met
him a bunch of times he's a lovely man
he's a very talented actor and it's the
stupidest untrue rumor in the history of
show business but
it's out there I don't know how it got
revived but I'm gonna look into it and
find out let's talk guests my guest
today
this guest deserves better oh my God
and this intro of oh my God gerbils
being fired through a pneumatic tube
into the bottom of a famous
foreign